tibet on vettech the world famous
mentalist and headliner of banach's mind
games live at the strat is here again
but this time making his big game
prediction
i'm very excited about this i'm a little
nervous about it are you if you're
nervous i'm nervous then because what
could go wrong right predicting the
super bowl you know yeah
i mean
out there there's a lot of people out
there putting money on it if they're
watching and they trust you well i'm
gonna tell them what it's gonna be ahead
of time yeah we're not gonna give it
ahead of time okay but i'm going to do a
couple of things for you okay so first
of all we should talk about the strat
like my show first let's talk about the
show yeah my game's live at the strat
right yeah at 4pm show time um we also
yeah family i'm actually dark this week
because we have semi hagar in there
they're bringing great bands and cheap
tricks coming in coming up xavier
mortimer's after me illuminates in there
as well so we've got a great great
lineup i want to get to this because
there's a couple of things we need to do
okay i'm going to put this down on the
table right here thing and uh wobbly
table yes we do have that and if you
take a look it says date winner halftime
final score and some miscellaneous and
what i've done is inside of this tube
right here okay yeah i put a piece of
paper right in there as you can see all
right and that's going to stay inside
there okay i'm going to close that and
what i want you to do is to take that
marker and you're just going to put any
mark you want it can be your initials it
can be anything that you want on the
very top
yeah and that's going to go right here
so far easy easy easy peasy
i'm gonna lock it up okay all right
gonna change the combination just a
little bit and you are going to keep
this box i'm gonna come back valentine's
day i hear earlier in the day of course
and uh we're gonna open it up and i've
made a few predictions i've made a
prediction of what i think the halftime
score is going to be okay i've made a
prediction on the final score and a few
other little goodies in there as well so
we'll see how close it is it's not all
going to be 100 but um i think i'll be
close enough to impress you what okay so
we don't get to actually hear
the predictions today you do not we got
to wait till monday to see if you were
right or right-ish that's exactly right
that's the whole point of it yeah okay
so let's talk about this wherever you
want to keep yeah i'll keep this safe
i'll keep it let's talk about what's in
the box though right um how do you is
there a strategy behind how you make
your predictions well there is to a
certain point what i do is i try to take
a look at the stats i take a lot of it
is my own gut instinct as well
the weird thing is when i second guess
myself or when i say something ahead of
time i tend to be completely wrong
so but if i just put it down don't say
anything to anybody i tend to be more
right i like that
you can use it as a lot of some life
advice huh absolutely yeah okay so how
can people get tickets to your show and
come see you you can go to
bannercheck.com uh you can hit tickets
that'll take you straight to the strat
side or you can go to the strat site
itself and then book it right there and
see when we're up when we're running um
yeah you know you still have to come to
the show i know i know i'm in for a
treat when i do come and then on monday
you guys are all in virtually you got to
check back in we will be seeing this is
going to be fun how you did this is
going to be fun all right yeah jc i'll
send it to you i can't wait to see this
on monday but first the big game is
sunday and coming up we have a few big
game betting options
and we're cheering on the big game
weekend with some delicious spirits from
distill and remedies las vegas now will